hello everyone and welcome to today's
life science and translational research
presentations
i am xavier gutierrez of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
sponsored by agilent
now let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like
during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
please address each of your questions to
a specific speaker
we will answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
i now present today's speakers first we
will have dr stephen
pennington founder ceo and cso of
atura's ltd
present on the topic of personal protein
signatures for precision medicine
then dr clifford dasho professor of
molecular and cell biology at baylor
college of medicine
along with his co-presenter dr arun
srikumar
professor and director of metabolomics
department of molecular and cell biology
at baylor college of medicine
will present on rewired metabolism and
diseases
biomarker and therapeutic applications
for a complete biography on today's
speakers please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr steve
pennington
you may now begin your presentation good
day everybody
um i'd like to start by acknowledging my
thanks to agilent for giving me this
great opportunity
to present us asms and i
renamed the title of my talk testing
times because of course
we are in very testing times indeed and
i think nobody would have anticipated
at the beginning of the year that we
would be having an asms
that was virtual and that we wouldn't
get the opportunity to to meet in
in person um but i've heard that ams
asms is going extremely well and uh hupo
likewise is going to have a virtual
conference in congress uh later this
year
and we just hope it can be as successful
as asms and this
event as part of asms um
of course when i put these slides
together in may of
this year um nobody realized that having
been
hit with a pandemic a viral pandemic the
world then was also going to be exposed
to
a re-emergence of of concerns over
racial inequality so these really are
indeed
testing times and i appreciate that all
of us are going through
um what is a quite remarkable experience
so i hope that you were all safe and
well what i'd like to do in my
presentation today is talk about the
development and delivery
of advanced protein tests for precision
medicine
and much of that work has taken place in
the conway institute which is the
building that you can see in the slide
and at the bottom of the slide you can
see some of the funding agencies that
have supported the research
that we've been doing i think it's
really important to acknowledge at the
outset
that part of the work i will describe
and the continued development and
delivery of of the tests that we're
trying to
to produce is being done in the context
of a small spin-out company
a ucd based spin out company that's
university college dublin
and that company is called achuros and
achuros really wants to
develop protein data for precision
medicine to deliver advanced diagnostic
tests
and date the data from them that will
have a global global impact
of course covid has affected all of our
lives
and i suppose what i tried to do here is
just capture some of the emerging
lessons because
one of the things i tried to do early on
during the cover crisis was really to
try to look for
for some of the positives uh if there if
there are many or any
um and i suppose one of the things that
we've all got used to dealing with is
is a new degree of uncertainty and
flexibility
and of course we've all been really
conscious of the impact of external
factors how
plans and and research plans can be
really
changed dramatically by factors that we
haven't been able to anticipate
i think one of the positives and
certainly from a public perception
is the importance that it's raised on
testing both dna and protein tests
and of course being able to do testing
at scale so i think science
has benefited from a public realization
that testing
is really important but of course we're
also conscious that these tests need to
be reproducible and reliable and i
suppose it's
there's a possibility that some of the
tests that are being developed
rapidly may not be as reproduced covet
tests may not be as reproducible
or reliable as we would like them to be
i think the other thing that that i
particularly realized is that of course
once there's a will to do something
there's enormous energy can
coalesce around that wheel and as my
granite used to say where there's a will
there's a way and it seems that we have
moved forward quite remarkably
in the last few months but we've moved
forward in the sense of being able to
test for covert and possibly being able
to manage and
ultimately treat this viral infection
disease
but of course chronic diseases the
existing diseases that individuals have
haven't gone away and as we come out of
the
covid lockdown in various um
jurisdictions it's becoming obvious that
the you know the chronic diseases in
patients with chronic diseases have been
slightly neglected
for the last few months and that's
something that we will have to deal with
amongst many other things so what i'm
going to try and do in the brief time
that i got available
uh is is give a sort of an introduction
to precision medicine
very brief talk about the early
development of protein biomarkers and
then how we might deliver those protein
biomarkers
specifically for some chronic diseases
and i'll end with some observations
so this gentleman leroy hood has a
vision for precision medicine and this
is him articulating that vision
at the 2017 cupola congress that was
held in dublin
to an audience of about 1500 delegates
and in leroy hood's vision of medicine
p4 medicine as he calls it
the future of medicine will be
predictive more preventative
it'll be very personalized and
participatory and so he envisages
that systems medicine driven by the
omits and the large data that's
generated as a consequence
driven through a digital revolution and
social networks will lead to this
new era of medicine
what's interesting from my perspective
is that leroy recognizes that many new
platforms
will have the potential to improve
health of individuals
in particular um platforms for
proteomics
will be important and leroy suggests
that's the case because um
proteins are the active agents in cells
and so measuring proteins
gives us a much closer handle on
physiology and i think many of us
appreciate and understand that but he
also acknowledges that realizing
the potential of p4 medicine presents a
number of challenges and at very many
levels
so that's the vision for prison
measurement of precision medicine of the
future what about medicine now well we
know
that it's very imprecise and this figure
just shows that i'm sure many of you
have seen it before
where there's a patient in blue that's a
patient who's been given a drug
and responded and in red the same a
different patient will have been given
the drug and not responded and this is a
list of the
the top best selling drugs in the u.s
and you can see that the very best
uh is effective in one in four patients
so that's medicine as it stands now and
so in many cases these top selling drugs
are only effective in one in 15 or 116
patients
and of course the the 4 or 15 or 16 or
have many it is patients who don't
respond
not only do they have the side effects
of the disease but their disease is
progressing so that's a double
negative hit and it's been suggested by
uh yamamato and colleagues that whilst
genomics
and is extremely exciting and we were
all excited about the sequencing of the
human genome and
the genomics revolution that's occurred
subsequently um
genomics in itself no matter how
powerful it is or economical
isn't sufficient to understand human
physiology and pathophysiology
and they suggested that we would have to
have this knowledge network
of data from different sources genetics
the microbiome
exposures patient contributed data
as well as new clinical tests to be able
to identify patients who will respond
to particular treatments or given a
particular um therapeutic path
to follow and it's our hypothesis
that the clinical tests that they
propose
would be could be new protein biomarker
tests
and that these protein biomarker tests
will be complementary to genomics and
add value to it
and so obviously these new tests are
going to have to reflect the
heterogeneity of individual diseases
and the variability of individual
patients including their co and
multi-mobility so many individuals with
chronic diseases
are multi-morbid and of course we all
know that environmental exposure and
lifestyle behaviors influence health
and there's so the clinical tests at
some stage are going to have to
incorporate
these important factors into their um
reckoning so combining proteins
data and and genomic data for some is
the emerging field of proteogenomics and
here we have a picture of joe biden
talking on proteogenomics
and his conviction that proteogenomics
will accelerate the pace of cancer
research he did that
in 2017 at the royal college of
physicians
in dublin um joe biden's
view of of the world is that um
we as a scientific and clinical and
medical community need to speak clearly
and engage with public
and patients we need to change the way
that we do
things change our culture but most
importantly
he implored during this talk and has
done subsequently that we should have
impact that as we
should do something to benefit patients
and that we should do
the sense of urgency so he firmly
believes that
you that's us have a huge opportunity
with the emergence of this new
omics era and responsibility to do
something
to use that that data to patient benefit
so of course what we would like to do is
to improve patient outcomes
using proteomics that is in biden's
words have some
impact and i suppose one of the ways we
believe that we might be able to do that
is by identifying better biomarkers
and those better biomarkers would be
converted to better tests
of course we're all patients and i'm
sure many of us will have had
this experience a venus blood draw where
blood is taken
and processed and then used to put to
under to
support the performance of a diagnostic
test so this is a test form from a
hospital
in in uh dublin's and vincent's hospital
and on the right-hand side there are
some tick boxes
for tests that are going to be performed
so venus blood draw is taken on the
bottom left-hand side
the sample processed and then taken to a
laboratory where the test is performed
and on this test
there are tests sorry on this form there
are tests for individual
proteins and one of these proteins is
psa many of you will have heard of it
prostate specific antigen
so this is a single protein test that's
measured in blood and indeed many of the
the probe that the sort of diagnostic
tests on this form
are for single proteins measured in
blood in the case of psa
that protein is measured on an automated
elisa as part of a diagnostics clinical
track and so in a very automated process
however psa although it's used for
prostate cancer diagnosis and there are
over 30 million psa tests per year
performed in the u.s alone
a high psa doesn't mean that an
individual man has prostate cancer
and a low psa doesn't mean that he
doesn't have prostate cancer
so for diagnosis this single protein
test although it's performed so widely
isn't good and most people know that
and it's also for prognosis that is for
predicting the outcome
of the cancer in the patient it's
actually worse
i think the similar limitations apply to
all of the single protein biomarker
tests
that are currently used by clinicians
to identify disease status in
individuals or diagnose diseases
in individuals so what i'd like to do
now is just talk about how we might
improve this situation by the early
development of protein biomarkers
and many will have seen a schematic like
this before where we begin with protein
biomarker discovery we identify some
candidate biomarkers
develop an assay to confirm that those
biomarkers
do really exist and change under the
conditions that we're measuring
and now assemble them in a panel not as
individual biomarkers but as a panel
and perform an evaluation of the
performance of that panel
in the hope that we might ultimately get
to a new clinical test
that can be split into phases of
discovery developing the assays
using those assays to evaluate the
performance of the
the biomarkers and then moving them to
some phase of clinical utility
i just want to emphasize that the
analytical validation step is extremely
important because what we need is a
reliable
and robust method of measuring the
proteins and if we don't have that then
ultimately we're not going to have a
test
there won't be any clinical utility so
what's the strategy for doing that well
within achuros
we held some brainstorming sessions on a
range of topics of clinical technical
and business development aspects
of trying to produce new biomarker tests
and of course the three
key elements are the content of the test
the platform
and its intended use but then there are
a whole series of questions and suppose
this alludes
to the complexity that leroy hood was
talking about and the challenges
and we know it's challenging and there
have been reviews on how
futile efforts have been some of the
known challenges have been reviewed in
numerous manuscripts
so we know that it's a very challenging
process
so i hope you can imagine my surprise uh
a few years ago when a young bright-eyed
consultant from cambridge
uh dean griffith said actually if you
want to develop and commercialize
biomarkers it's
really simple all you've got to do is
identify
need come up with a solution and scale
it
and of course he was right and so in our
case that would be identify a need
discover and develop the biomarkers and
then deliver them
for their use and and that made us
realize that what we really needed to do
if we were going to try to develop a new
test was to start at the end
um unfortunately i don't think this
slide has projected there should be a
very
large start at the end box in the in the
middle of the of the slide
and by that i think oh sorry there it is
now um
by that i think what we we need and mean
is that we have to start with the
clinical unmet
needs uh and identify that need and the
clinical test that will address the need
and then develop and evaluate the
biomarkers against their intended use
and of course as basic scientists we're
not in in best place to understand what
the clinical needs are
and i think that requires a very close
association with clinicians
and who work with the patient groups
that we're interested in or
in chronic diseases so i'm just going to
change tax likely and i just want to
just
talk now about what i think has
transformed or has the potential to
transform our ability to develop new
biomarker tests
and that's peptide multiple reaction
monitoring i'm sure many if not all of
you know
exactly what peptide mrm is that's
identifying a peptide as a surrogate of
a protein
and quantifying it in a triple quad mass
spectrometer predominantly triple quad
mass spectrometer
i we think as do many others that mrn
will play a key role
in developing analytically validated
measurements
for protein biomarker candidates and
then
being enabling the clinical validation
of those multiple
protein biomarker candidates
um what happens then and has happened in
a number of
studies is that once the clinical
validation has been performed and the
panel of a small panel of protein
biomarkers has been identified
individuals have then and developed
elisa's to to use those elisa's
as a clinical test and and so support
clinical utility and in many ways that
seems a really sensible thing to do but
i think for
reasons we can't spend time on today i
think that it
that it actually isn't and and the
reality is that it's proving very
difficult
to develop eliza's multiplexed elisa's
to proteins that have been discovered
and validated and clinical validation
undertaken using mass spectrometry based
methods so i suppose ultimately our
hypothesis is that mrn will be the
clinical test
platform as well as being the platform
in which the the protein biomarkers are
evaluated
and clinically validated it will be the
platform under which the tests
uh are performed of course
mrm is is very popular we we developed
our first multiplex to mrm i say in 2006
and so we've been doing it for a while
i think there's still from my
perspective a little bit of uh
um not sure how to put this uh
a bit of over expectation about what an
mrm
assay is so it is
undoubtedly an ability to measure a
peptide
that that peptides measured in a sample
that the
mass spectrometers would may refer to as
a matrix it requires
liquid chromatography to separate
peptides and mass spectrometry
to detect and quantify them and an mrm
as if it's going to be effective needs a
lot of quality control
and i think one of the things i'd like
to try to emphasize is that what an mrm
assay once you've identified a
prototypic peptide and transitions that
you may want to measure in the mass
spectrometer
and a retention time under various
liquid chromatography conditions
it isn't a universal assay for the
quantitation of that peptide or protein
it's very very sample matrix
and any pre-analytical steps that you
may have taken with the sample
so we spent a number of years and and i
transferred this to atturos
developing a protein biomarker platform
and the and the biomarker tests that
we're trying to develop are
multiple protein and we measure multiple
blood proteins do it simultaneously and
precisely
the workflow supports accurate and
reproducible data that is that they are
analytically validated
the data that's generated is processed
by machine learning approaches
predominantly random forest approaches
and we then develop an
algorithm that's that allows us to
create an
easy to interpret score for whatever um
distinction we're trying to establish
and within atturos that now is a protein
biomarker workflow and we're
enormously grateful to agilent for
enabling them but for them enabling us
to to develop this workflow
in which everything is carefully
controlled sample tracking and
processing
and pre-analytical steps are extremely
important
uh that the processing then is done in
an automated way we're talking here
about tryptic digestion
and then those samples go on to triple
quad mass spectrometers predominantly
6495 series of mass spectrometers and
the data analyzed by machine learning
approaches
and where we can it the data is then
integrated
with other clinical data and all of this
requires a series of mass spec
process controls and method
pre-analytical method control so a lot
of standardization so this is really at
this stage it's
it's more product development than it is
research
so what i'd like to do now in the in the
brief time that i've got available is
just talk about
delivery of some protein biomarkers for
chronic diseases and i'm going to focus
on
uh three areas that atturos is working
on that's prostate cancer
in the middle psoriatic arthritis on the
left and kidney disease
on the right hand side in the case of
ceramic arthritis the current time
average time to diagnosis of that
disease is eight years for a precise
diagnosis
that means that patients aren't treated
appropriately until
for a very long time after their initial
presentation to a rheumatologist
in prostate cancer we estimate that
at least 300 000 men per annum globally
could be spared in invasive treatment
for their disease that is they could go
on something that's called active
surveillance
and in the case of diabetic kidney
disease about sorry in the case of
diabetes about
30 of of patients go on to acute kidney
failure
so these are identified and significant
clinical unmet needs
and what i'd just like to do now is just
pick one of those and that's ceramic
arthritis
um and and just mentioned in a few
slides what we've been doing in the
domain of psoriatic arthritis
so we're very fortunate i think this
slide has been slightly um
um scrunched but in the in the domain of
psoriatic arthritis we've been very
fortunate to work with a clinician
oliver fitzgerald
who's one of the world leading
clinicians in psoriatic arthritis he's
the incoming
president of a group called grappa an
unfortunate acronym but it stands for
the group for research and assessment
of psoriasis and ceratic arthritis it's
around a thousand dermatologists and
rheumatologists worldwide
and obviously as i say is the incoming
president
so radical arthritis is a complex and
polygenic
autoimmune disease and it has diverse
clinical features and you can see
some of those features here ranging from
uveitis information of the eyes
spinal involvement it is associated with
psoriasis
so about 30 percent of patients with
psoriasis will go on to get heretic
arthritis
it's also associated with pitting of the
nails dactylitis that swelling of the
digits
and very characteristic joint erosions
in its most severe form psiranga
arthritis mutalens you can see
that the deformities that it induces are
life-changing
individuals with these kinds of of
bone and joint changes really can't uh
operate and function within a normal
existence
most patients with surrogate arthritis
also experience significant
pain and that in turn can lead to
depression so it's a
it's a very disabling disease in itself
uh and around one to two percent of the
general population that's two to three
million adults in the us and about
half a million adults in the uk have
cyrillic arthritis
so we've been trying to develop protein
biomarker tests that can support
the diagnosis of psoriatic arthritis and
the way that we've done that is to do
discovery where we've taken
existing panels that we've had
candidates from the literature
and done our own discovery experiments
to come up with a panel of candidates
that we then develop mrn tests for and
analytically validate those tests
and over a number of years we've been
doing that in in ceratic arthritis and a
number of other arthropathies including
rheumatoid arthritis and juvenile
idiopathic arthritis
and come up with a panel of around 206
candidates
inflammatory arthritis biomarker
proteins that we target in measuring 432
peptides
and we do that in an assay that we call
the paprika method and this just shows
some of the properties of that assay
the important thing is that the mean
peak area cv
so that's the ability to quantify the
peptides is less than 10
for all 432 peptides so if any of these
peptides
prove to be valuable biomarkers the
assay has been developed sufficiently
for them to become incorporated into a
test
so that's what we've done we've taken
that panel and we've tried to clinically
validate it
in cohorts of patients i'm just going to
show a snapshot of one of those
and that's a cohort of patients that
have ceramic arthritis
versus rheumatoid arthritis and in a
modest number of patients so just under
200 in total
we were able to measure the per the
peptides in the paprika panel
and show that a subset of them can
discriminate between ceramic arthritis
and rheumatoid arthritis
with an area under the curve of about
0.9 so that's a very high
area under the curve and 90 probability
that we can discriminate between
those two diseases and so we spent some
time now
surveying rheumatologists as to whether
that would be something that would be
valuable to incorporate
into their clinical pathway and it seems
that they universally agree
that it would be very valuable because
of the challenges associated with
diagnosing ceratic arthritis
and that it would increase the title so
it would decrease the time it takes to
make that diagnosis
and allow them to intervene at an
earlier stage in the disease
so the next steps because this still is
at an early stage is for us to use
oliver's connections in the grappa
network to access
high quality clinical samples and their
clinical expertise
and undertake a clinical validation
study so we're in the process now
of designing and getting access to the
samples for that clinical validation
study
and then we very much hope that if that
clinical validation study proves the
the power of the of the test uh in being
able to discriminate psoriatic arthritis
from rheumatoid arthritis
it will be adopted and disseminated by
the kol's
and of course we're really fortunate to
be connected and killed into
cater inculcated rather with this grappa
network
because they're the group of clinicians
who set the clinical guideline
guidelines for psoriatic arthritis
so a sort of a whistle stop tour of some
of the work that we've been trying to do
and some of the limitations that may
exist
so i'd just like to end now with an
overview uh
i'm sorry with how we might deliver
these protein biomarkers
for chronic diseases and it turns out in
collaboration with
the gemelli hospital in rome we've
identified that in our initial test
delivery model
where the sample is sent to us the
central authors laboratory
for performing these assays getting the
sample to the laboratory is the most
challenging and expensive part of the
process
so with the gemelli and with colleagues
in in theoterex we've been exploring
uh whether whether serum placed on
quantitative sampling devices called
meteor tips
could be used as a way of of shipping
the samples at ambient temperature
dry and at ambient temperature to the
central laboratory
and in early experiments we were able to
show that we can perform these tests off
serum that's been dried on the meter
tips and on the right hand side you can
see there
that the peptides that we measure are
stable at ambient temperature on the
meter tips
for a significant amount of time so we
think this provides an important
logistics step
in terms of getting samples to a
laboratory that can
process and and undertake these
diagnostic tests
so this is just a summary of where a
choice is up to in terms of its pipeline
of tests in psoriatic arthritis
in prostate cancer and through a test
that it's licensing in from a company
called proteomics international
in australia that the test pro marker d
in kidney disease
um and it shows how we're trying to
progress these through this pipeline
so i'm just going to end with some key
messages
um i think it's clear to all that many
new tests are needed
to support this era of precision
medicine to go from the very ineffective
approach we have at the moment
to perhaps the vision that leroy hood
anticipates
and the expectation is that they will
measure multiple biomarkers not single
and i suppose that they will also
measure proteins
as well as as genes and genomics and
metabolomics so
we think protein tests are good but when
combined
with other omics measurements whether
that's genomics or metabolomics or
lipodermics
they will together add value and be
better it's clear that mass spectrometry
has made a huge
impact on many clinical tests and i
haven't had a chance to describe those
small molecule tests
where it's routinely used but we believe
it's poised to do the same for new
multiplex protein tests
the other messages well we know it's
challenging
but we believe it's achievable and
indeed i think we're possibly not alone
in believing that it's achievable but it
still
is proving extremely challenging
so i think it just remains for me to
acknowledge my colleagues have made all
of the ceratic arthritis work in
particular possible
and specifically oliver fitzgerald and
the team of clinical
scientific statistical and external
collaborators that we're working with
but also to thank
agilent technologies for providing us
and working with us to develop this
biomarker workflow
and the platform on which we perform
these measurements of course the most
important individuals to thank are the
patients because it's their samples
that we use in this development process
and we're really fortunate that the
grappa network
includes significant representation from
the patients
and we engage with them at the very
early early stages
and keep them engaged with everything
that we do so finally i'd just like to
thank
the early colleagues in aturos uh
agilent perkin element near terex
our colleagues in the jamali hospital
and and merck
who've helped us develop some of the
analytical validation and the steps
required for analytical validation
and then just show you the scale of the
turrets as it stands at the moment
it's still very embryonic as you'll see
so this is the small
achuros team they're really focused on
developing this next generation of
protein biomarker tests
so i'll just leave it to thank you then
uh for listening
uh and for and i hope then to be able to
answer some questions or any questions
that you might have
thank you hello my name is cliff dasho
and i'm a professor of molecular and
cellular biology and medicine at baylor
college of medicine and with my
colleague dr aaron srikamore we're going
to talk to you today about
metabolic reprogramming in cancer
and specifically focusing on biomarker
development
i'm going to spend the first couple of
minutes talking in general about
screening for malignant disease as well
as for benign disease
and the criteria that we use for
screening and for the development
of a test using metabolomic criteria
so the first criterion for a screening
test
is it has to be a significant disease
there are a lot of tests for which good
screening tests would be available
but the cost and effort required to
perform those screenings
make it not viable so the the
second part of that is that the disease
has to have a high prevalence why is
that
well one of the reasons for that is
bayes theorem
which says that the posterior
probability that is that
the likelihood of a test giving you
useful information
has a strong dependence on the pretest
probability so you'd like to have
a high enough prevalence of the disease
in the community
to circumvent the abyss of bayes theorem
the third thing is that early treatment
would be beneficial that is to say
in illnesses where the
where the disease itself is not amenable
to treatment or
treatment does not make much of a
difference why do the screening to begin
with
we have to ask for a test that has a
high degree of specificity and
sensitivity
and although not on this slide by
uh implication has to have a reasonable
um positive test
predictability and then the last thing
is the screening has to have a low
morbidity and low cost
with follow-up testing available so
these
are roughly six criteria that are
generally used
to decide for whether a screening test
should be inaugurated or not
the converse of that is a list of four
items of when screening is not favored
if the disease is rare as i said before
it's not serious
or there is no effective treatment or
public health import
then one would not embark on a screening
program
if the population prevalence is unknown
one can still
do screening but has to we have to use
the right mathematics for understanding
the ability of a test to give
a diagnosis or the converse
a negative to be a true negative if
there is no benefit to treatment that is
no intervention
is indicated then there's really no
reason to do screening either
and lastly and this probably is an
absolute
specificity and sensitivity cannot be
determined
uh in that case it really wouldn't pass
muster
as a valuable screening test
for the point of view of prostate cancer
you would think after all these years we
would have this one locked in that we
would know exactly
how to do screening for prostate cancer
when to do it and who to do it on
but at this point other than limiting
prostate cancer screening to men
there's a lot of a lot of dispute still
in the literature
the u.s preventive services task force
has strong recommendations regarding
prostate cancer
and these recommendations are i should
say at this point
relatively fluid because actual practice
varies
for the most part after age 60
men are asking for screening tests for
prostate cancer
i certainly experience this in my
clinical practice
that i might be even in the even in
the setting of shared decision making
the people are requesting prostate
cancer screening they'd like to know
why their expectations are that we'll be
able to catch the disease early
and intervene another controversy
excuse me is the heterogen heterogeneity
of prostate cancer
we are all familiar with the gleason
categories and their implications for
clinical
practice but there's more to it than
that and the heterogeneity of prostate
cancer
and the impact of genetics
is still understudy and somewhat
controversial
number four is perhaps the most
important which is their disparities of
access
and treatment different populations have
different access
to urologic care for biopsy
and cancer care for treatment
these are geographically distinct
they're economically distract
distinct and these disparities have a
major impact
on whether or not to embark on a cancer
screening
effort and then lastly there is still
controversy about treatment strategy
is radical prostatectomy the treatment
of choice is
external beam radiation the treatment of
choice how about
watchful waiting or expectant
observations
where we do no active intervention but
the man
needs to come back for a repeated
cancer diagnosis all these are
controversial they're large studies
pending
uh and we ought to have information on
this in the
[Music]
relatively soon but we don't have it
right now
one of the most important aspects from
our perspective are
from our our research program but also
from public health and clinical aspects
is that african-american men have
prostate cancer earlier and worse than
european american men
or asian american men for that matter
and this chart from
uh 2017 shows that
beginning at the moment of diagnosis and
continuing on
as far as the eye can see the
prostate cancer-specific mortality
is higher in black men than it is in all
non-black men and this graph
informs our target population we're
thinking about the screening criteria
that i talked about earlier
the the money really is we have a
population
where intervention uh would be important
where we have a test with a known uh
positive predictive value and we have a
population
of high prevalence and if you throw in
other aspects like
family history of prostate cancer this
curve
gets even more acute and screening is
even more
indicated so
how what are the opportunities for the
metabolic
characterization of these cancer
diversities because in african-american
men
just like in european and asian men and
non-hispanic whites the
metabolic characterization of cancer
diversity
determines the treatment and in this
situation
an appropriate screening test will give
this type of information
to inform further treatment whether that
be a chemotherapy strategy
an immunotherapy strategy radiation
where we can predict radiation
responsivity
we'd like to be able to make some
predictive statements about response to
therapy
and even more importantly because we
know the
the biology of this disease it's
important to be able to have a test
available that will give us a high
degree of
ability to perform surveillance for
recurrences
so in terms of the vulnerable
populations
for prostate cancer
it is a large number of people
uh a large number of these people will
require primary tests
and us even more will require
confirmatory tests and even more will
require primary tests
and we see in the future that there's
going to be a significant growth in this
population
what are going to be the drivers of
those growth of that growth the
utilization of the screening test
one is aging of the population
prostate cancer is not a disease of
youth
as time goes on there are going to be
more and more effective treatments
there are a number of effective or a
number of treatments now
in clinical trials more are coming the
pipeline is large
it's going to be really critical as i
talked about earlier
to be aware of differential populations
not only in terms of their
susceptibility
to disease but also their education
about the disease
because for an effective screening
program to be embarked upon
we have got to have a high degree of
awareness
in the population that screening would
be beneficial for them
and then lastly the effectiveness of
testing
is a critical critical issue
one that really drives the entire
program
so now i'm going to turn this program
over to my colleague dr aaron srikamar
professor in the department of molecular
and cellular biology at baylor
who will talk more about the
metabolomics
thank you clay for that is a great uh
introduction uh
on prostate cancer and the clinical
management of the disease um
i'm going to be now uh talking about uh
how we have used metabolomics as one of
the platforms
to try and understand some of the
biological changes
that are associated with prostate cancer
in african-american men
and how we plan to use this information
to develop
markers for early detection of the
disease
so to begin with um as you all know
metabolomics is basically the
um is an is a technology that's
that's used to detect the steady state
levels
of small molecules and metabolites
so in our study we have used a mass
spectrometry based
approach uh to look at metabolic
alterations
and our first step in in in the study
was to
look at metabolic alterations that are
associated
uh with prostate cancer of
african-american men
which here is abbreviated as pca um
relative to the metabolic profiles
in the benign adjacent tissue so the
benign adjacent tissue
is basically the unaffected
pathologically unaffected part of the
prostate that is flying right adjacent
to the tumor
so what i'm showing you here is a
snapshot of
the of all the metabolic alterations
that were identified this
is a heat map uh wherein shades of
yellow show or
represent metabolites that are elevated
while shades of blue
are represented metabolites that are
down regulated
and metabolites are arranged on the
y-axis
or on the rose and the columns are the
columns represent the samples
so a quick quick look at the heat map
uh tells us that there are metabolic
alterations that are associated with
prostate cancer in african american men
compared to
matched banana adjacent tissue and if
you look a little
further and i'm specifically just
highlighting names of certain
metabolites that belong to
a particular pathway which in this case
happens to be the methionine
homocysteine pathway
also known as one carbon metabolism
pathway
and you can see that majority of the
metabolites in this methylene
homocysteine pathway
seem to be elevated in prostate
cancers in african-american ventilated
relative to
the adjacent benign tissue
so one way to look at this data
is to represent it in in a pathway
context
which is what i have done in the next
slide which is basically a network
diagram that shows you how these
metabolites fall into various pathways
the major pathways that are
most highly enriched are are shown in
red circles with a blue background and
the
nodes the bridges they basically
represent the interaction between the
various pathways
uh nevertheless the take-home message
here uh if you look at it very carefully
is that among the many pathways that are
enriched one of the ones that was most
highly enriched was
the cysteine methylene metabolism
pathway which i'm showing you in the red
forms right in the center of this
picture so going to
what's cysteine methionine homo methane
homocysteine pathway
methionine homocysteine pathway is
represented in this particular slide
when methylene that's derived from the
diet is converted to acidity methionine
which all of you know is a ventilation
currency
and when the when essentially methylene
donates methyl group it gets converted
into acid and oxyhomosystem
and then stoichiometry
stoichiometrically breaks down into
homocysteine and adenosine
so based on the heat map that i showed
you a couple of slides
uh prior to this one uh i've shown you
that some of the metabolites in this
particular pathway were elevated
and i had highlighted metabolites namely
methionine homocysteine adenosine
cystothionin and so on
so the take-home message here from
the first set of profiling experiments
that we did was that there was elevated
levels of methionine and homocysteine
in the tissue um specimens that were
obtained from
um which are either which from prostate
cancer tumors
and related to that just benign tissue
so we went ahead and then tried to look
a little deeper into this
so the next slide we did a validation of
this findings
in plasma and here i'm showing you three
box plots and these represent two
different patient cohorts
on the left i'm showing you the box plot
for
the levels of homosystem the relative
levels of homocysteine in a case control
cohort
and this involves african-american
prostate cancer patients
and african-american case controls
and you can clearly see here that the
levels of homocysteine are significantly
elevated
in the plasma of african-american
prostate cancer patients relating to the
case controls
uh panel b and panel b is
a independent cohort which is called
what we call as a biopsy cohort
and uh here this is derived from
patients who come into the clinic with
uh elevated levels of psa and
uh go through biopsy to
detect or detect the presence of cancer
so the samples here are collected from a
clinically
challenging population of patients who
have elevated levels of psa
and who have abnormalities that
require them to go through the biopsy
and the samples are
collected prior to biopsy and the
results are then compared
to the biopsy results and as you can see
here we have a biopsy positive cohort
and a biopsy negative cohort
all patients in this cohort are
african-american men
and uh it's clear that patients uh
individuals who have a positive biopsy
have higher homocysteine levels
compared to individuals who have
negative biopsy within uh within this
cohort
containing african-american men
panel c is again the case control cohort
that i described in panel a
but comparing the levels of homocysteine
in african-american prostate cancer
african-american men with prostate
cancer compared to europe and american
men with prostate cancer
here again you can see that
african-american men with prostate
cancer have significantly elevated
levels of homocysteine compared to
the european american counterparts
this kind of again verified our original
uh findings that homocysteine levels
seem to be elevated
in african-american prostate cancer both
at the level of the tissue that i showed
you earlier
and at the level of plasma
so the next question we had was is there
an association between
uh the levels elevated levels of
homocysteine and
the west african ancestry that's what
i'm showing you in the next slide here
where you can clearly see that when you
take all samples into
consideration both um and this is this
this analysis was done in the case
control cohort
when you take both the cases and the
controls into consideration
um there is a significant uh correlation
between west african ancestry and
elevated homosystem levels as i'm
showing you in panel a
and in panel b this association remains
when you only look at the prostate
cancer cases but
it's not evident when you look at the
controls showing that
there is a correlation between west
african ancestry and homocysteine levels
in the serum
are the patients who
have prostate cancer the next
interesting
finding is when you further dig into
this a little deeper
you'll see that the west african
ancestry is having a
has an odds ratio of 18.5 to have high
levels of plasma levels of homocysteine
that means west african ancestry
per se increases the probability of
having elevated plasma levels of
homosystem
in these individuals
the next slide shows shows you a little
bit about
why one of some of the reasons that
would explain these elevated levels of
homocysteine in these patients
here uh in panel b and panel c i'm
showing you data from tissue microarrays
where we are comparing the expression of
two proteins
uh in panel b i'm showing you the
expression of
a betaine hydroxy metal transferase
which is an enzyme
that re-methylates homocysteine back to
methane
and on panel c i'm showing you the
expression of cysteine in beta synthesis
which is an enzyme that takes the
homocysteine and converts it to cystitis
in both cases as you can see the
expression of these proteins in both
africa
in african-american prostate cancer is
significantly lower
compared to european american prostate
cancer this could partly explain the
elevated levels of homosystem that we
find in african-american prostate cancer
patients that i've shown you in the
previous slides
having identified this the goal of our
experiment the goal of our
research is to see how we can use this
information
to develop markers that can be used in a
non-invasive setting
to identify or to detect the presence of
cancer or the presence of prostate
cancer
in african-american men so for this
we have a collaboration with agilent
there's a collaboration ongoing
collaboration with agilent and beta
college of medicine
whose the goal of this collaboration is
to develop a high trooper
non-invasive lc msms-based metabolomic
signature
for early detection of prostate cancer
in african-american men and as dr dasho
uh
mentioned earlier during his talk
um african-american men with prostate
cancer have two times higher mortality
rate compared to europa american men
and the patients that we are using in
this biomarker development
strategy all these patients have a
significantly high elevated levels of
psa which is clinically significant
which in this case i've indicated that's
greater than four nanograms per ml
and or have an abnormal digital
technical exam which
either of which necessitates that they
go through a biopsy for
confirmation of presence of cancer in in
the case this
for the study we have collected all the
samples prior to biopsy
an important thing that we all need to
note here is that thus far
there are no biomarkers defined for
early detection of prostate cancer in
african american men and as dr dasher
indicated
early detection of prostate cancer in
african-american men could be
beneficial because it will give an
additional
it will give a window of therapeutic
intervention that would benefit these
patients where the tumor were in the
tumors are pretty aggressive
so the question we have is can plasma
levels of these metabolites
distinguish biopsy verified prostate
cancers from
biopsy negative controls
to do this we have done two sets of
pilot studies
both involving samples plasma samples
collected at the time
prior to biopsy as i mentioned my
previous slide the first pilot set
contains about 47 samples
of which 20 are from african-american
biopsy positive patients
17 are from african-american biopsy
negative individuals
and five each are from a european
american biopsy positive and biopsy
negative individuals
in pilot set two we have an additional
72 samples
which which include 34 from
african-american biopsy positive cases
24 from african-american biopsy negative
individuals
and seven each from biopsy positive and
biopsy negative european
um american individuals again this is a
pilot study
but it is it basically lays the
foundation
to develop to show that metabolic
markers
would be would have clinical value
in as diagnostic markers
so next slide shows the preliminary data
that we have
obtained using a multi-multi-or
multi-metabolite panel this includes
multiple metabolites that we
have identified in our study
and as you can see the this is compared
with psa on the right
for the population of patients i just
described in my previous life
and it's evident that the metabolic
panel per se
has a superior area under the curve with
an roc of 0.71
for uh early detection of biopsy
positive status
in uh african american men compared to
psa which is
which has an roc of or of 0.56 which is
uh just equivalent to about the toss of
the coin
so this uh pilot study
uh that we have begun in this
collaboration
um basically um
we hope to we hope to carry this forward
and we hope to develop a biomarker panel
that can be clinically utilized
that would benefit african-american men
and help early detection of prostate
cancer in these individuals
the team that's involved in this
investigation involves
dr bert o'malley and dr cliff dasho uh
myself
uh dr nagini deepakuri and dr g gohey
thank you oh
thank you all for your informative
presentations we really appreciate it
uh we will now start the q a portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
and we'll get to your question so let's
get started here
the first question is going to be for
uh dr steve pennington
um about how long do the protein
biomarker mrn methods
take to run
lovely so thank you for that question
it's a good one
it obviously depends on the number of
proteins that we're
measuring
peptides the shorter the assays itself
um typically in the earth we try to keep
the asset
as including many proteins as possible
but as we're moving towards refining the
battles
the assays um that people can show
that's a long answer to a short question
and i haven't
that yet to say that the assets take
anything between five
minutes two minutes to run spectrometer
thank you and uh following up is
how is psoriatic arthritis currently
diagnosed and where will these tests be
performed
in hospitals
okay again for that question uh at
present ceramic arthritis there are no
diagnosis
for it so it's a clinical uh that's made
and predominantly uh the assessor and
the gnosis depends on the the skills of
the assessor
and their experience and they are
looking for signs of inflammatory
real skeletal disease in the presence of
of
involvement and skin circumstances but
those can be very
hidden features and indeed psoriasis may
not be present at the time of
of presentation um and so it is a very
challenging diagnosis
to make and that's why we and
rheumatologists have been working with
believe that a test that could aid in
the diagnosis would be a very valuable
addition to their skill set sorry the
other part of the question was
uh where where will these tests be
performed
yeah so uh again that's interesting i
think that
our expectation is that in the first
instance this will be
performed in central laboratory
facilities but ultimately
they may dive into hospital laboratories
if the instrumentation the mass
spectrometry based instrumentation
can be provided in a format that's
amenable to
to hospital laboratories and of course
there are mass spectrometers currently
being used in
in hospital labs for measuring small
molecules like immunosuppressants
and and things like vitamin d and i
suppose we anticipate that in the future
uh those mass spectrometers are
equivalent mass spectrometers in
hospital labs
would be able to analyze the the panels
of proteins that were developing
here
thank you our next question is going to
be for arun um
arun what methods were used to come up
with these pathways and visualize them
yeah that's a great question um we used
a
um a methodology called
net gsa it's a network-based uh
network topology based method that
basically takes into account the
underlying interaction
between biomolecules in a network
setting
and uh this particular topology
enrichment method
uh basically uses a mixed effect uh
mixed effect linear regression
uh framework and basically conducts a
formal hypothesis
test for uh to come up with pathway
enrichment so this is basically called
net gsa
and we basically visualize this using
our program
and we basically used a program within
the r
uh rr console which is called a model
kawaii
and is there a signature for uh
castration resistant prostate cancer
um yeah great question so what i spoke
earlier
uh during my uh what i presented earlier
was basically
trying to look at uh prospect cancer
that was organ confined which is what we
call as a localized pressure cancer
and cancer-resistant prostate cancer is
advanced to use
which is basically associated with as
you know resistance to second generation
anti-androgens so
when the prostate cancer recovers or
comes back which is what we call a
biochemical recurrence
and um at that point you know when the
patients start getting treated with
second generation anti-inflammation
therapy and then they become resistant
to that
that's when we call gastric resistance
prostate cancer which is in fact
considered the lethal disease and we
have done uh analysis to look at
metabolic profiles in gastroparesis
disease
compared to for example organ confined
disease and we see
significant alterations or signatures
that are important significantly
specific to gastric resistant disease
um again it all depends on the drivers
that are associated with crpc or cascade
resistant disease
uh in in for example we do see in case
of uh
the crpc we do see changes in lipid
metabolism to be uh
happening uh significantly we also see
changes in carbon
uh utilization uh where you know and and
there's a switch
from being an amino acid dependent tumor
which is what we call as an organ
confined tumor to a
uh sugar dependent tumor which is what
we see in case of crbc
and one more uh do you think that there
is a test to predict recurrence
um at this point um there is not really
a good you know molecular test
out there to look at the auto predict uh
biochemical records most of these
productions of
these and clinical mammograms are there
are efforts um
that are being uh put in this field both
uh using
uh like genomics uh proteomics and
metabolomics to look at uh monitors that
could be or
molecular signatures that could be used
to predict
the probability or the potential of the
given indication having the iconic
records but that's still uh in early
research
well thank you thank you our next
question is going to be
for aaron um can metabolomics be applied
to following men
with prostate cancer
yes i think there is a huge potential
for metabolomics
to be used in the biomarker world
especially for uh
following the progression or the
trajectory of the disease
uh you know the important thing about
metabolomics is it's basically
uh it basically reflects the
physiological state of an individual at
any given time point
and so as we can be easy it's
non-invasive you know it can be detected
in
biofluids and so what that allows us to
do is it allows us to do longitudinal
testing
and allows uh you know allows us to
develop signatures for
uh progressive disease versus disease
that is involved
and so i think definitely this is still
a field that's really coming up and i
think
there's a lot of potential in using
metabolomics trying to
monitor disease progression
and do you anticipate that metabolomics
will allow early detection of prostate
cancer
in african american men well i guess uh
the entire
hypothesis there is that there is a
biological difference that exists
between
uh you know african-american and
prostate cancers of african-american men
and
american men although there are other
variable other factors that also could
contribute to this disparity which
includes socioeconomic status and so
uh so forth health access to health care
and other things
but we do see biological uh uh
differences which
in this case is differences in metabolic
profiles and we do see some alterations
in pathways which
we believe could be exploited to develop
metabolic tests
for early detection and that's
my hearing okay
okay well unfortunately we won't be able
to get to cliff
but gentlemen again i want to thank you
so much for
your time and your important research we
really appreciate you um
before we go i'd also like to thank the
audience for joining us today and
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed to the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed through on
demand through
the end of geo 2021
until next time goodbye
thank you thanks bye